so what are the top ways to keep each
other safe and be very careful when
you're using public restrooms and those
doorknob they all potentially could have
the virus on it we know the virus can
live for up to three days that's a long
time on a surface you see me wearing
glasses now because I've stopped wearing
my contact lenses for the time being and
even if I'm washing my hands just
engaged and I'm touching my cuz my
contact is dislodged that's not good
that's how the virus gets into our
system something I learned a long time
ago a little trick if you're out and you
have no other option your eyes bothering
you I will simply take the inside of my
shirt because it's much less likely the
virus is there then on the tip of my
finger simple measures matter not
touching your face trying to avoid close
social contact avoid social gatherings
right now if you can do that you limit
your risk you limit the risk of those
that you love even washing your hands
with regular soap and water it's not all
just about your hand sanitizers it
really is good old-fashioned hand
washing makes a difference
[Music]